Zig and maja along with probably collet
oh hold the distinction of being some of
the lesser-known zoldak sin the series
however I'm here to inform you that the
least known family member of all is
subscribe zoldak who is an even bigger
stain on the family the Miller key
because all subscribe Tzadik does is
push that enticing red button to ensure
that he receives regular Hunter hunter
content uploaded straight into his
YouTube feed and look he's an
underachiever in the world of assassins
but I certainly do appreciate him hello
and welcome to the new world review your
source for everything anime and manga
and snake we're going to delve into a
discussion about a fairly mysterious
manga figure of Hunter hunter being a
certain zigs older now if you're an
anime only watcher chances are you will
not have heard of this particular zoldak
before but I would encourage you to stay
a while and listen because there's some
fairly intriguing stuff at play here for
a character who has only ever been
officially seen in one panel as a result
you're probably going to be seeing that
one panel quite a bit in this video and
for that I apologize for in advance but
as for margaritas I'm sure that a lot of
you have also seen the runtime of this
video and might be scoffing to yourself
over how exactly I can say anything of
substance in regard to such a seemingly
fleeting existence but to tell you the
truth even I was surprised at just how
much there was to potentially digest
here so without further ado let's begin
examining Zig zoldak through his
contextual appearance in the manga so
Zig would make his first and currently
only appearance in chapter 344 as part
of a flashback featuring Isaac natural
landing on the Dark Continent in his
youthful days well comparatively
youthful days I guess and this was a
supposedly unrecorded trip even though
Jing freak seems to know all about it
but we do know vaguely Wynette Row was
there which was in search of a strong
opponent something that the Dark
Continent was unable to provide as the
only victory there is that of survival
but on this trip Metro brought two of
his young pals one of which being Lynnae
hors d'oeuvre a name that I was
crucified for not being able to say in
what has become by far the most popular
video on this channel because I am
uncultured swine
but in my defense even toe Gashi sucks
when it comes to French and you know
languages in general actually choosing
to Remini's each foul three explorers
names very bizarrely and inconsistently
which may actually become a point of
relevance to this discussion in regards
to the third part of this dark continent
menage tois zigs old ik now Zeke's
reasons for traveling to the Dark
Continent alongside metro and lenay
a 100% unknown at the time of this
recording and in truth it seems wildly
inconsistent with everything we know
about the zoldak family past far as the
world's most established an infamous
group of assassins the Dark Continent is
not something that should appeal to them
from a business standpoint because there
are no clients and there are no targets
it's just a gigantic game of survival of
the fittest
without a profit motive but there are
some possible explanations for this one
of which is that at the time of Zeke's
generation zoldak may have not been
involved in the assassination business
because to the best of my knowledge it
has never been stated exactly how long
result ik family have been assassins but
it does seem to be incredibly deeply
rooted but then again at the moment we
can really only dive back at least five
generations with the oldest confirmed
Celtic family member currently being
maja zoldak the grandfather of Xena and
the great great grandfather of kilwa who
is somehow still alive and well to this
very day and trying to see where Zig
fits into this family tree is a bit
difficult because there is only one
unaccounted for place which is in
between maja and Xena the figure
represented in a sort of hey Hachi from
Tekken style of look one that obviously
immediately does not match up to the
established image we have of Zig
although it should be pointed out that
the portrayal of this figure being the
son of maja and father of Xena could
just be what Zig came to look like much
later in life because the image we have
of him on the Dark Continent is quite a
young whippersnapper and in fact if we
directly compare nettles previous look
to his more modern incarnation we can
see that an awful lot can change over
the course of what I assume would have
been potentially over a century the
thing that does give me the most pause
for thought here though is that zigs
facial structure does not match this
mystery man at all this guy has
relatively thick eyebrows a very
pronounced nose and a teeny tiny mouth
thing whereas Zig has super thin
eyebrows a tiny nose and a long mouth so
if anything zik resembles maja
significantly more than maja son and
that brings us to a very intriguing idea
that has been floating around for a
while which is the possibility that Zig
is in fact maja zoldak and based on
aesthetics alone I am incredibly
inclined to invest in this idea because
seriously maja just looks like an old
man Zig they are the only members of the
Tzadik family who have a head that seems
to be more wide than it is tall which is
reflected in all of their key facial
features but the main issue that seems
to stop this idea in its tracks
is the fact that they are both
separately named characters or are they
I mean yes yes they are but it's very
interesting to
that maja was never actually named in
either the manga or the anime he was
just some old man zoldak dude who made a
very brief appearance and his name was
only revealed in the 2004 Dada book
which was released about 12 years before
chapter 344 featuring Zig and I point
out that massive time difference because
you know over time hunter hunter has
developed a wide array of
inconsistencies many of which I do hope
to do videos on Monday but twelve years
well that's an awfully a long time in
togarashi land long enough for him to
change his mind in regards to the
established facts of the world and
decide that no this guy is actually this
guy and at this stage I should also
point out that if this were any other
series I would never ever propose such
an idea but because this is hunter
hunter literally anything is possible
plus if you were to take the context of
the manga alone it just makes perfect
sense if your only source material was
the manga and you didn't have that pesky
maja name from the data book then this
probably wouldn't be so much of a
discussion on speculation as it would
become a practically established fact
and not just because they share
aesthetic similarities either but
because it also makes sense based on the
greater context of the world
specifically in relation to zigs dark
constant comrades natural and Lynnae now
up until recently both of them were
alive and well that is until natural
sacrifice himself to prevent the threat
of the Chimera Hantz Lynnae is still
alive though and was even put forward as
a candidate to become the next chairman
of the hunter Association but the fact
that she is still alive is nothing short
of incredible just as it was with
natural Butlin a currently presents a
rather withered existence very similar
to that of maja but these characters are
all absurdly old and nerd that is not
necessarily a common feature in the
Hunter hunter world as we have
characters like Zeno who is a
comparatively youthful 67 years old and
portrays aging like the normal world
lifespan of a human being natural Lynnae
and maja are all a very unique existence
and there is a possible explanation for
how these three in particular have
managed to live for well over a century
which has to do with you guessed it the
Dark Continent because one of the
reasons why humankind continues to
conduct expeditions to this hellish
landmass is because it contains
creatures items and substances of
immeasurable value the kind of stuff
that would really revolutionize a
species and one such sought-after item
is known as nitro rice the consumption
of which is said to be able to extend
one's life and I would imagine that
naturally the
you consume them all that life is
extended effectively granting you a form
of immortality so long as you engage in
constant numbing and so if maja were to
be Zig then that provides an immediate
explanation as to how these three select
individuals have been able to maintain
their bizarrely long life and it doesn't
necessarily have to be nitro rice either
there could be any number of other
incredible objects or substances on the
Dark Continent that are capable of
performing such a thing the specifics of
it doesn't really matter what matters is
that the one thing they all have in
common is stupidly long life and the one
place that can provide that is the Dark
Continent
and for posterity's sake i should also
say that this does not necessarily mean
that Zig is maja if anything's it could
be a brother of maja who Jenny but
natural and upon his return gifted my
heart with nitro rice or whatever was
used but I find that explanation
honestly just a little bit harder to
believe because if such a substance was
brought back to the human realm then it
would surely have revolutionized more
than just the life of one man whereas in
reality it seems more like a thing that
the Dark Continent trio would have
consumed in a desperate survival
situation and they may not even have
necessarily known about its effects and
once again if maahes name wasn't in a
data book published 12 years ago then we
wouldn't even need to find an excuse
like this it's only information from a
notoriously unreliable book that stops
everything from falling perfectly into
place but putting the zig maja business
aside for a second it's also an
interesting discussion to ask a bit more
about the actual Dark Continent voyage
wid netter o because there's one that we
know lines up almost perfectly which is
the journey instigated by the member
Republic which landed at the south shore
of Lake Mobius now quite notably this
was not the expedition in search of
Nitra rice the proposed longevity
substance but instead they were hunting
for something known as the Trinity
elixir which is a very vaguely defined
mother solution for all sorts of liquid
great societal value however by the end
of this expedition there were only three
survivors which is a very magic number
given that we only know of three
individuals of Metro's expedition and
three individuals that up until recently
were all still alive plus this
particular voyage is also what brought
back the calamity hi and just quickly in
case you're not familiar the calamity is
something imposed on humanity by it
being known as the guide in what we can
only assume is some sort of punishment
for their exploration of the dark
continent and there are currently five
established threats who were brought
back via this method and one cost upon
the human race in this case was I a
gaseous being or group of beings known
in full as a codependence of desire
I'm not going to go into this here
because I've done a whole video on it
link in the description below if you're
interested but I is almost 100%
confirmed to be nanika the ghastly being
that currently inhabits a locker zoldak
and has the ability to grant seemingly
any desire upon the fulfillment of
certain conditions so upon initial
thought it would make perfect sense for
the member republic expedition to be the
one which involved metro Lynnae and Zig
as the threat brought back has directly
infected a member of the Zeltiq family
and any other explanation would be a
pretty huge coincidence because of all
of the people in this boat bond with it
just happened to be the descendant of an
individual who has been to the dark
constant himself however as convenient
as this is there are a couple of
problems with this theory one of which
is that Jing freaks the stated that
Network conducted this voyage
unofficially and effectively snuck into
the Dark Continent with Lynnae and Zig
meaning that it's highly unlikely that
they would have been associated with the
member Republic trip and furthermore
it's also been said that all three
survivors of this member Republic
journey had lost all of their sanity as
a result of encountering I the second
part doesn't overly concern me though
because we've seen nothing of Linnaean
Zig and or maja that truly proves any
semblance of sanity and does for Isaac
métro himself well sanity is not
something that I would serve readily
accuse him of having possessed and I
suppose now we should also state the
possibility that Zig did not survive his
trip to the Dark Continent because we
only have solid confirmation that net
row and the nae have been seen alive in
the modern day discounting the whole
Zegers maha idea of course i mean i
highly doubt that he would have perished
with such powerful hours by his side but
until any further confirmation is
achieved the possibility definitely
remains and going back to the question
of why he may have chosen to travel to
the dark continent in the first place
other than because he and Netru were
bestest friends forever he may have even
had business there because we do know of
at least one human figure who seems to
be something of a permanent resident of
this hellscape which is dumb freaks so
imagine for a second of always exotic
for whatever reason is given a lucrative
contract to assassinate dawn and thus
potentially being the earliest known
freak zoldak interaction which would
culminate down the line of many many
generations in the world's most
unbreakable bond between gone freaks and
killers old ik in any case as it turns
out
Zig zoldak is a far more intriguing
figure than a simple one panel
appearance would suggest and that pretty
much does it for this discussion about
ms
does exalted if you enjoyed this video
and the content this channel produced in
general and please do consider donating
to the new world review patreon because
the support of all of your amazing
people is what continues to make this
channel possible and if patreon is are
quite your style and please do leave
this video will like share or subscribe
because it also helps for this channel
an incredible amount and if you'd like
to join the fun at any time then please
do head over to my disk or server where
a wide array of Shangri takes place on a
daily basis and finally please do
comment with your thoughts on zigs or
dec this has been the New World review
and I'll see you next time
[Music]